bonsoir la querelle sur l'école
prendra-t-elle la même ampleur qu'en
1984 mais à front renversé cette fois le
conseil constitutionnel vient en effet
de prendre une décision importante
à trois jours de la manifestation prévue
par la gauche contre la révision de la
loi falloux il censure en partie le
texte voté par le parlement
il déclare contraire à la constitution
l'article 2 de la loi sur les conditions
des dans l'enseignement privé des
collectivités territoriales c'est
l'article essentielle comment réagira le
gouvernement à cette décision applaudie
par michel rocard
nous écouterons en direct sur le plateau
de france 2 le porte parole du
gouvernement et ministre du budget
bonsoir nicolas sarkozy bonsoir mais à
voir les réactions et les commentaires
les faits en d'autres termes
l'explication de la décision prise par
le conseil constitutionnel
nathalie saint cricq
anticonstitutionnelle la révision de la
loi falloux les neuf sages en ont décidé
ainsi au nom du droit et de la
constitution l'article 2 de la loi était
nulle et une censure sur le fond qui
intervient après plusieurs semaines de
polémique ayant opposé edouard balladur
à françois mitterrand et socialistes à
l'actuelle majorité
c'est au nom de l'égalité entre
enseignement public et privé que la loi
a été partiellement censuré l'article de
incriminé prévoyait que les
établissements d'enseignement privés
sous contrat pouvait recevoir une aide
financière à l'investissement de la part
des collectivités locales le conseil a
considéré qu'il n'y avait là aucune
garantie du principe d'égalité entre les
établissements
tout d'abord pas d'égalité entre public
et privé les établissements privés
pouvait recevoir de l'argent avec un
plafond élevé alors même qu'ils ne sont
pas soumis aux mêmes obligations que les
établissements publics notamment en
matière de carte scolaire rupture
d'égalité aussi 10 conseils entre les
établissements privés tel établissement
privé aurait pu recevoir un million de
francs un autre établissement privé
voisin lui 0 franc zéro centime bref une
censure au nom du principe d'égalité
entre établissements scolaires censure
certes partielle du texte mais qui vise
pour l'instant la révision de la loi
falloux de tout son contenu